elle est où maman elle est pas là on
s'est disputé hier soir alors elle est
sortie
[Musique]
les parents de la disparu sont arrivés
vous croyez qu'on peut participer en
recherche on va pas rester là attention
rien faire bonjour mademoiselle
Boiron et votre belle-mère c'est ça vous
l'avez entendu cette dispute
[Musique]
quand son corps était emporté par le
temps Madame Boiron a fait une chute
mortelle qui n'a rien à voir avec les
inondations
vous avez des nouvelles de l'enquête
elle aurait pu glisser
ou être surprise par une bête ou un
chauffeur c'est pour ça que la capitaine
vous a posé des questions sur votre
voiture l'autre jour pardon
maintenant tu parles plus à personne
t'as rien vu rien entendu je veux pas
que tu sois impliqué
homicide mon dieu
c'est parce qu'il s'est passé c'est pour
ça qu'il enquête Alexandre cet accord
vous pouvez me dire ce que vous faisiez
dehors à cette heure là il y avait quoi
dans sa poubelle
si tu sais quelque chose il faut que tu
le dises ça va te pourrir la vie il
n'aurait pas dû te laisser faire ça tout
le monde me manque tout le monde se sert
de moi
de menace la vérité c'est mieux pour
tout le monde tu verras vous avez tué
votre épouse
tu crois que je l'ai tué
[Musique]